because we just rehearsed an entire
proof I'm not going to do all the
working PRP I'm you've got the beats of
the proof here that you need to move
through but I just want to make a couple
of quick minor notes before we leave
okay so let's go through first refactor
eyes mutable this completing the square
and this is where you want to land okay
you read off the easy features yes
that's fine you pop those easy features
there and baby into B squared equals x
squared 1 minus is going and that gives
you an excellent hristian now I'll just
make a quick note where you left it as
rude eight on three or you simplified it
to reach you on three is not the issue
like you probably should simplify as you
will see later on that makes these
fractions implants they are literally a
faction support but now that's not what
my focus ii i'm here we're not mainly
worried about concerns now please note
this look up at this your japan down for
a second you can catch up he's not going
anywhere okay please note this because i
didn't write it last time in a way to
make a big deal about it a penguin I
think as soon as you said don't having
the extra screen get that number right I
think you should say you should
specifically identify since the major
axis ears and then tell me tell yourself
what the major axis is you can see it up
here right here it is there's a major
one and because of where I've written
you can see it attaches to the wine
right and then you've got the minor axis
over here I hope you can sense my
frustration at the hundreds of students
I have marked when everything is fine
but they don't even think to work out
which one is major which one is a minor
so then they completely just screw the
pooch on this so I'm going to say since
the major axis is vertical and I make a
big deal about it right that's my game
into saying well now I know which forms
i should use right the plus or minuses
got any happening on the variable access
on the way that's why it's there and
then of course you would cap your shift
so i think the numbers we ended up
getting were in the air one was a two
plus or minus six or two
I think and then what are we going to
hear y equals 2 again plus or minus have
it write something it's like it's got
its 2727 the fabric and of course just
like we said before you can maximize 127
be two on four but it's it's neither
here or net there if you've done the
hard work and by this point you've
definitely otherwise ok